a new frontier in ethiopia's war
rebels integra say they are advancing
further south towards the capital addis
ababa
the federal government has declared a
nationwide state of emergency
prime minister abe ahmed has asked all
ethiopians to mobilize and fight back
against the rebels
there are many challenges but i can tell
you with certainty without a doubt we
will score a comprehensive victory
in just a few days the rebels from the
northern tigra state say they have
seized the towns of desai and kombolcha
which are in the neighboring amhara
state
the two are on a major highway leading
to the capital
the federal government has disputed
those claims
we have to make sure that our children
are not dying from hunger and services
we have to make sure that there is
access to medicine access to food by our
people so we'll do what it takes to make
sure that the siege is broken if we're
going to add this marking to others is
what it takes to break the siege we will
the united states has warned the tigrai
people's liberation front or the tplf
against any such move let me be clear
we oppose
any tplf move to addis
or any attempt by the tplf to besiege at
us
there are concerns that violence could
escalate with tigran rebels joining
forces with the oromo liberation army an
armed group in the region surrounding
the capital others there is a new
marriage of convenience alliance
between
at least a faction of the
oromo liberation front and the tplf
because abby has managed to alienate
the oromo
the uh including samam haras so he is
really increasingly isolated and the
tplf is trying to take advantage of that
situation as well as ola
and its families like these who are
paying the highest price for the
shifting battle lines of ethiopia's war
that's dragged on for nearly a year
more than two and a half million people
have been forced to leave their homes
and around four hundred thousand are on
the brink of famine
priyanka gupta al-jazeera
well let's remind you of the key events
in this conflict it began last november
that's when the prime minister abhi
ahmed ordered a military offensive
against the tigrai people's liberation
front he said it was in response to
attacks on army bases the tplf says it
was unfairly targeted later that month
abby told parliament the military
operation in tigray was over but in june
this year tigran fighters captured the
regional capital mikhail
by july the tplf entered the neighboring
amhara and afar regions to the south
in october the government launched a
ground defensive to push out the rebels
and as we mentioned the tplf says that
in the past few days it's seized two
towns on the road that connects mckelly
with the ethiopian capital addis ababa
well joining me now in the studio is al
jazeera correspondent mohamed val
muhammad how bad can this get
well it i mean it depends on several
factors
the first factor is that they are now
the closest to the lifeline
that links addis ababa and ethiopia in
general
with the port of djibouti
they have been trying to to close this
block this this road for several months
there have been attempts close attempts
but now they are the closest to that to
that line if they can block it
then ethiopia is undecided economically
and remember the economic factor is very
important
many
indications that the country is facing a
huge economic crisis
31 embassies and consulates have been
closed down
or the government decided to close them
down last month across the world that's
a huge indication
if you see the footage of the of the
soldiers and the paramilitary they sent
to the front lines some of them they
don't have shoes they don't even have
military issues
uh lots of reports about economic
problems so this can it can only worsen
because of the cost of the of the
fighting of the equipment of the army
and so on
the other factor is that now
because we have also the oromo
we have a liberation front
liberation army in the south south of
adi sabiba and west west in particular
and they have
they have
struck an agreement with the tplf
and now
the problem they have been divided
geographically they couldn't reach each
other and
become a contiguous front now they can
do that the reports say that they have
now
the the approach of the tplf has allowed
them to meet with the uh with the aurora
fighters and the other fighters have
been trying to even reach addis ababa
from the from the west and the southwest
so if the two fronts come together
that's very that's that's very dangerous
because it's i mean it can yeah well
this
could represent something of a turning
point really in this conflict which
let's face it has been ongoing for for
very close to a year now
do you think that's perhaps why the the
government has declared this state of
emergency they recognize the fact that
the momentum
is shifting in the conflict there is no
doubt about it the state of emergency
means the government can do whatever it
wants they can force people to to to
carry arms take up arms and they have
actually called today on the population
you know people to come and register
their weapons so that any time i mean
they can be called to go to the front
line and so on we have seen waves and
waves and waves of civilians even very
young people being sent to the front
line that's that's been a pattern over
the last several months and now it's
like everyone in addis ababa is called
on to to come and register their weapons
maybe they will also give them weapons
and that's that's an indication of how
dangerous the situation is in addis
ababa by itself and also remember that
there is a political factor which i
didn't mention in my first reply
this government
that has just come to you know to to
rule after the elections i remember he
uh who was sworn in only last month i
think
and this government is very loosely
connected
it's a it's a it's he promised abi ahmed
the prime minister he promised a
national dialogue and he promised that
after the elections
there will be a government of a strong
government of national unity
that will come as a result of a national
dialogue and a national consensus but
that didn't happen there was no no
national dialogue happened
now it's a it's a bunch of individuals
who say they represent
different areas of the country
they came together to to create this
prosperity party but actually there are
doubts about their uh their uh the
loyalty of of their wider population to
these individuals it's not like before
before it was a coalition of parties
each party represents a region from
ethiopia now it's a coalition of
individuals and there is a lot of you
know
a lot of opposition within
the constituencies of those individuals
and also there are two polls in the
government the oromo
the oromo they create a strong block in
this government who are of course
against ahmed i think he has he has
prevented them from having their rights
and so on they think they are the
majority
population in the country and they are
ruled by minority the the amhara and you
have the amhara bloc so the government
itself is under threat because according
to many observers it hasn't been founded
on a strong base on a strong uh on
stronger principles or foundations okay
so very complex situation and of course
ethiopia a very complex country with
many different
nationalities and ethnicities or other
ethnicities and groupings within that
country uh we'll keep a very close eye
on this mohammed valdo thank you so much
for talking us through the the various
dynamics at play in this
changing situation